hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play when life
no longer exists okay
we just entered the sewers which is
always a good place to be
well we didn't just enter the sewers but
we came down here anyway from some other
thing that I was running away from that
I don't really recall anymore oh yeah
that damn it you son of a [ __ ] I didn't
think you were gonna oh hey I need to go
through there hey I need to go to there
maybe get through a box at you
pooja hello where are you
are you ah they ride up what the hell
one of the guys stupid [ __ ] with that
how is he able to just pop up and never
buy nevermind I need to take some
curative liquid no longer called law
down down and thence go on my merry way
because guys a son of a [ __ ] anyway
we're in the control room what point of
that was that to have a little bitty
baby part right there where he could be
whatever whatever Oh long hallway okay
what are you remembering how to turn
your head incorrectly I remember someone
saying to me that sometimes machines are
controlled by forces of darkness let me
think
oh yes it was in the sauna a few years
ago why just gah yeah chill now naked in
the sauna how y'all doing
way no am i moving oh I thought I was a
chillin chillaxing take your clothes off
no thank you
I've been alright alrighty then yes sir
I'll have a seat oops no my shirt okay
oh hi naked guy well at least that
explains why this particular guy is
gonna be naked
I'll take scoop I have seat you're
really weird man but okay I do what you
I scooped you or what well oh oh maybe
there's already watering it yeah what
kind of system are are you talking some
more water
what would you in the water
alright fine I put more steam on water
do you do the yeah mmm how much more
water do you want cheese I'm trying like
I'm the pursuit wow wow oh man if there
are any like writers out there don't you
know that this is is like the most
shoehorned method of telling a story
about how some plot device it's going
forward what in the world they that have
to do with anything
chapter 2 yeah Oh whoopee oh man those
nuts I mean cool that you could do that
in the amnesic mechanics but it's story
wise it was so arbitrary Oh flashback to
some thought I was and some guy was died
by a machine that killed people that
somehow relates to this house that I
just bought and am now I'm trapped in
the long winding basement of what Inge
either way I'm being overly critical
about the story okay what do we have
down here what am I waiting for it's
dark
got some strange noises what is that
tingles my ears in the headphones okay
why what did that have to do with
anything there's some broken barrels
here and that started turning up some
whoop did it get brighter got brighter
all of a sudden why what happened
already then I'm leaving here hmm hello
whoa Oh No wow I just murdered that guy
didn't even our guys do it oh I'm sorry
what well I don't know man [ __ ] happens
it was just you got in a bad situation
man there's nothing they could be whoa
he's gone don'tdon't unta oh hi dude are
you all right I need me to get her out
yo yo yo you are creepy oh man you're
creepy okay are you where are you are
you behind me hello you're gonna come
this way maybe I shouldn't have done
that news but just leave me alone
boop-boop can I hide in here he's just a
dude hey he's not even a monster I mean
he's kind of bloodied up and he he's
that ah you're gonna get it now friend
Oh get ready you ready for the pain map
out oh that didn't work okay we're gonna
go on now sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry Fran
aah Eider run up which one I did neither
ha ha ha ha I went straight up to him
and smacked him in the face which
apparently was not the correct solution
when you're confronted by some deranged
monster creature don't run up and smack
him in the face with an axe that's for
other games
I like this well done this is well done
done done done done and then the monster
spawns no masters gone ah that sucks but
I'm fortunate but the way half life half
life yes the way half life works is the
scripting sometimes when you die doesn't
cause the monster to respawn oh well I
guess I'll just have to carry on without
him I could have quite easily hid from
him so let's just assume that I was pro
enough to beat him at his own game and
not let's just assume that when I
smashed him in the face with the ax he
died and it's gone forever
hooray everybody we did it
congratulations
we did it high-five self-five
yeah I'm the best okay so that was
wasn't that all the was there one more
lever that I missed or something
something I don't see a lever I didn't
see a lever when I was going into these
places
I don't nothing mmm-hmm I don't see a
lever where the hell listen there's got
to be another level in one of these
rooms if wasn't mom what the hell what
is this douche nozzle miss I can't even
pull back up how much candle I've lived
not enough I wish dude it probably
really hard to do but I wish there was
someone sort of a visual indicator right
here like I could see the candle slowly
going down but I imagine that'd be
really hard to do and it's cool enough
that there's a candle anyway huh
door won't open stupid spike block mhm
that didn't look like it hurt those
aren't even sharp what is this baby
whining about probably why he wasn't dad
he was just complaining too much alright
there's that noisy
well what the hell I don't have any more
of these damn switches okay hang on
there's got to be something that I miss
somewhere around here no not down there
it's got to be down this way but I
didn't see any other switch swatches it
was this one the one in that room and
then the one over here this total of
four I mean how many more could there be
this can't be right maybe something went
wrong with the scripting when I died oh
no oh no oh God good golly I hope not I
hope not
Oh No Oh something might have gone wrong
oh no I bet ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
oh yeah be worried for a second there ha
ha but I am too bro how did I miss that
how did I miss that one were you all
like no bargain bar just the left it's
like one of those bats takes place where
there's like guys look like where is the
monster and he's like right behind him
who knew it wowee right behind you look
around and I know it's too stupid it
noticed that's not good
I'm not worried okay this looks like a
sort of dungeon area I'm guessing what
no no I know I know a trap when I see
one that's a trap all right let's bring
the trap
hi oh I thought it was - I totally
thought that was gonna be a trap
oh wow that was like wait a minute did
you that totally looked like nari never
whining fine thought something was gonna
jump out okay how about that one which
one of these is the trap
not this one smash smash mash okay not
that one we got a dead guy I ate the key
good for you now prepare to be sliced
open
haha perfectly normal
an old rusty key or a rusty old key
sorry I'm Dyslexic hello did you die
here answer right no okay he died well
it isn't that convenient isn't it it are
convenient what the oh okay
helloo helloo helloo dude to downy how
about up up and then down and you down
you up how about you down and you hahaha
I'm too good for all these do these damn
puzzles here too smart alright let's see
what else we got
now I'm not saying that the puzzles are
hard I'm just saying that I'm a super
genius okay more jail cells always good
always good always good hmm
see another cave-in man they never
really need to check the structural
integrity of this place about opening
the door in big Hall you need to start
winding up three machines heating system
cooling zoos and pressure system when
each one of these machines are running
the door shall open without problems can
I open it with problems okay so we got a
series of doors that lead to different
areas I'm gonna go there in just a
little bit but all those barrels of
blood or barrels of wine hard to tell
whoa oh I thought I saw something in
there sorry I'm dumb I'm I'm on the
lookout for more switches because I
missed the other one hello
you something are you something you
something nothing has a glow so I don't
know which is something which is not
some hello rope nope okay yeah you know
one thing I haven't seen in this custom
story yet my angel lady Joe's head I
need to start all three systems no
kidding
okay yes it's like a friendly price
hello is anybody home
does anybody want to oh I found a bucket
of water that'll be convenient for
something many barrels of wine I'm
guessing and nothing [ __ ]
no thank you there's some behind there
is edges of something hi
I'll go in this room thank you Oh piss
is nothing in this room you didn't hear
anything breathe didn't hear anything
you just calm your tits calm your big
ugly oh thank you good boy please don't
come in here nothing to find in here oh
boy I can't move without moving these
barrels
that's not tall enough I need to hide
maybe died no don't come at her no come
here
I'm not ready my hidings body isn't
ready you didn't see anything bro don't
see any don't come in uh uh-uh not gonna
work it's not gonna work
hi hey good bow bow well I was talking
about you being ugly and all that I
meant that you were so beautiful you are
so beautiful you're the light of my life
you make my days bright when they are
gloomy and dark yep this is very true
and I'm gonna distract you into going
over there that didn't go very far okay
when you throw a barrel don't do it
really [ __ ] like I don't must oh where
is what are you doing what are you doing
what am I supposed to do here ah
why hide a run I'm trying
hiding didn't work running didn't work
either
this whole game is rigged stupid game is
dumb this game is dumb anyway is he
still here is he still there oh there's
a note over here you need to add water
manually to this system it goes into the
cooler and then lock this in oh come on
I could have done that in two seconds
then I would have been out of here okay
catid water and then something about
manually manually starting the system
well where does that poet hang on wait
what did I say exactly goes through the
cool and then to the lock system okay so
maybe it's already done okay maybe
that's it anyway I'm all out of time
anyway so I'll figure this later so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
ha
Oh
yeah